- That's my tired face,
and my impression of
every pug on Instagram.
Hello guys,
welcome to Sun-Diary.
Usually it's Fri-Diary,
a Friday vlog version of my week.
A catch-up, if you will.
But, uh, I didn't get
this edited on Friday,
so now it is Sunday night,
and it is Sun-Diary.
I just got done a long day
of podcasts for Not Too Deep,
which were really, really fun.
Oh, we shot podcasts last
weekend and this weekend
with so many great guests.
You'll see.
Let's get into it.
Sun-Diary is a look back
at my week in vlog form,
so let's look back at some
of the things I've done this week!
(funky music)
Lou and I have just participated
in a challenge video.
It ended like this.
It's really important.
- It's soggy.
- (laughing) It's soggy,
but not sucky.
So, soon.
Soon, soon, soon.
Yeah, we just filmed an episode
with Meghan Tonges.
And Mitchell Davis is here,
his face has become a light.
Look at this beautiful light.
- It's me, hi.
- [Grace] Meghan Tonges.
- Yay, yay, yay!
- [Meghan] We killed it.
- Hello, Fri-Diary.
It is Thursday.
Wow, what a way to start this.
I am headed to set.
I'm losing my voice a little bit, oh no!
I'm headed to set for day four
of shooting Dirty 30 Movie!
It's been so much fun and so cool!
And, uh,
today we have so many amazing people
on set today.
That's been the coolest thing.
We shot Camp Takota two years ago,
and for the most part,
other than background or extras,
it was Hannah, and Mamrie and I.
And this time around it's a house party,
so there is a whole slew of characters
that are interacting in the film.
And a lot of people that are our friends
from different walks of life
that we got to get in the film,
and it's just been so much fun.
Here's a look back at the
first couple days of shooting.
Good morning, we're blocking
scene one on day one.
Whoa!
- Then we'll house...
- [Grace] Look at these two!
- And we're back.
Welcome to first day.
(funky music)
- [Grace] ♫ Dude party
♫ It's a dude party
♫ Dude party
♫ Dude party ♫
Royalty free.
- You don't have to,
but if you want to show
them that you're looking,
you can just like...
- Forward it?
- This is Andy,
he plays, no spoilers but, whoa!
And Mamrie is teaching him
how to use social media.
She retweeted one of his tweets
and now he's freaking out about
how to talk back to people.
(laughing)
- For your cheek bones.
Talking about our cheek bones in here.
(laughing)
- She said, "I want your
cheek bones to cut me."
(laughing)
- Yup, that, you know...
- It's obscene, sadist...
- And Grace is her icon, so...
- Wow.
Do you, do you know about this?
- Hi guys, We're on Dirty 30 day two.
We have, Jell-O shots have been upgraded.
And we have Mikey Murphy.
- And my mail.
- And his mail.
And she's here.
Gang's all here, guys.
We just came back at the end of the wrap,
oh well, the wrap of day one,
to find these in our room!
- Oui, oui!
- [Grace] Oh my God, amazing!
- [Voiceover] So sweet.
- [Grace] So completely sweet!
(funky music)
♫ Hello from the outside ♫
(murmuring chatter)
- [Voiceover] Why aren't we, um,
Why aren't we getting a
little bit more into that...
- [Grace] Tight quarters,
tight quarters, tight quarters,
tight quarters, tight quarters
- Night Court.
(laughing)
- [Voiceover] Thanks so much, guys.
- [Grace] Hey, Dames.
- Hi.
(Grace laughing)
- [Grace] This is what happens
when you're trying to do Mamrie's makeup
after Dan makes her laugh so hard.
- [Voiceover] The second
before saying the line.
Thank you.
- So anyway, guess who, baby?
- Today on set, I believe
we have Rhett and Link.
Ohhh,
outfit of the day!
- We're being filmed, man.
Is that girl filming us?
- Yeah.
She looks like she's
gonna run somewhere, too.
(laughing)
- Oh, Drew Monson is on set today,
which I am so excited about.
He is quickly becoming one
of my favorite YouTubers,
and one of the funniest
people in my digital world.
It's day three.
♫ Day three, day three ♫
Four, four! It's day four!
It's day four, it's day four!
Jesus Christ.
Look who's here, Drew's here!
Yay!
And that thing's here.
And we're being quiet, and it's day four.
And it's day four.
So let's get to set
and watch really funny
people be really funny.
What a beautiful day.
Hey, morning.
- Morning.
- [Grace] Look at this camera crew.
They decided to wear, oh yes,
Hawaiian shirts on Friday.
- No one gave us the memo.
- And then this happened.
(funky music)
And so now it is Sunday night,
and I am editing Sun-Diary,
or I'm about to go edit Sun-Diary.
And I am exhausted.
And we get back into shooting
Dirty 30 tomorrow morning.
Um, what do I need to tell you guys?
If you havent RSVP'd
to the Dirty 30 party,
make sure you go to dirty30movie.com
and do that.
Also, Hannah, Mamrie and
I are coming to Australia
in December for some comedy shows.
Melbourne is already sold out,
and the tickets are going quickly,
so get your (mumbling).
Can we caption that?
(mumbling)
Also my second book is
coming out in February,
and I am sooo excited.
So if you want to
pre-order Grace In Style,
The Art of Pretending You Have It,
there's a link down below to do so.
Gracestylebook.com.
Um,
I think that's it.
You're great.
I almost said, "You're Grace,"
which would have been a cute way
to have an existential crisis on camera!
Girl has massive existential crisis...
can't function,
could be the title of this video.
I don't know.
You guys realize that YouTube titles
are becoming a mockery of themselves.
(chuckles) Right?
I can't do it anymore.
I can't do it.
JoshuaDTV,
I'm a big fan of the vlogs,
watch 'em all the time.
I clicked on (chuckles) video,
"Massive wave attacks boat,"
and just love it.
Keep it up.
It's working, and it's great,
and just it's so funny
how everything is so dire.
Everything is the end of the world
or the beginning of the
world, it's fantastic.
What should I title this vluh, vlog?
Vluh, vlaw.
"Girl loses capacity to speak!"
Exclamation point, exclamation point.
(chuckles)
Sorry, I am exhausted.
I mean no harm.
Now I'm talking to you like you're aliens.
Like I'm an alien.
Which is probably the case.
Okay, gotta go.